so the numbers are pretty big for the
french reunion the hbo max
it almost reached the same numbers as
wonder woman 1984
so 29 of all streaming audiences checked
out some of the friends reunion over the
past few days
that's just below the 32 percent that
wonder woman reached
yeah so in other words it's pretty huge
with so many people watching
there has been some concern over matthew
perry's uh matthew perry's appearance
he of course has struggled with
substance addiction in the past
but on the hollywood reporter's top five
podcast the reunion director ben winston
says matthew was just fine on set for
the love of god mute your microphone
matthew who doesn't pick up i don't hear
from anyone
the best way that i can describe it is
after the show was over
at a party or any any kind of social
gathering
if one of us bumped into each other that
was it that was the end of the night
you just sat with that sat with the
person
all night long i remember that was it
you apologized to the people you were
with but they had to understand
you had met somebody special to you and
you were going to talk to that person
for the rest of the night
and that's the way you're laughing and
crying because it's so true that's my
good work
it's certainly the way it works with all
of us
it's just the way it is
[Music]
yeah i'm going to cry now there's been a
lot of speculation i hate to even have
to ask this but there has been a lot of
speculation about his health in recent
years
how was he is he okay yeah he was great
um he was great i think you know people
can sometimes just be a little bit
unkind
and i wish they weren't um you know
he was great i loved working with him i
think he's a brilliantly funny man
and uh i thought he had some great
one-liners in the show
and yeah i felt just happy to lucky to
be in his presence and directing him on
something like this
yeah absolutely
alice's addiction sometimes makes people
look sick even after they're sober
and the closest people's comments about
matthew have been gross did you did you
expect him to be a hundred percent he
admits to not even remembering
some of these uh times i mean yeah i
mean they're all
a little older i mean it's actually
funny nicole saying he admits not even
remember some of these
times i watched the whole thing this
weekend it's shocking the amount of
things that none of the cast members
remember
like there's one moment where they all
signed the back of one of the sets this
big wooden board that they all signed
none of them remember that happened
so there's a lot of things that i don't
remember but yeah i mean i did notice
matthew's appearance a little bit but
yeah what do you make of people
commenting on it so much oh my goodness
well first of all it was said that he
had a dental appointment prior to
filming and i just want to say you know
anybody who is sober or struggling with
any type of
addiction the worst thing you can do is
falsely accuse them of anything
that can be very triggering i hope this
experience in general didn't trigger him
because you know to be on a show like
friends it already comes with a huge
amount of fame that can be really
overwhelming we see how big
those stars have become and and what
that show means to so many people but to
be
magnified and critiqued at that level is
very hard for anybody and he's human and
people have been wanting this reunion
forever
and it's like you finally get it you
didn't need to be
negative or be mean it's like that it's
just not nice um
if he was intoxicated if struggling
whatever it may be
it's sad if it was medication to fight
addictions you know maybe
that caused slurring whatever the
reasoning behind it it really is none of
our business
um you know we're allowed to be
concerned and care for him you know
he is beloved we i will say he is
absolutely beloved people love him
but the negative critiques and the
meanness it's just like it's unnecessary
like we don't need to
tear people down for our entertainment
like haven't we had a tough enough year
as it is yeah yeah tesco says he's a
brilliant funny man let's focus on that
um ninja says the connection they have
with one another is really very sweet
yeah he had some great one-liners like
some improv one-liners
a third special and yeah reality is like
he has i mean he's been open that he's
you know been to rehab a couple times
then
it is gonna affect you a little bit as
you get older like i mean yeah i did
notice his
face and look i think all six of them
had some botox right before this
right before they recorded this thing
because all the faces were looking a
little bit
stressful i mean he's definitely had
some work done on his face like they all
have so
yeah i don't mind people having concern
about him it's just a matter of yeah
when that
turns to negative energy and you're
making fun of him earth like that